oh this is nuts
[Music]
oh my God that's so embarrassing
isn't that crazy
oh this guy
Century delicious fries
my man
but there's also a a burger element to
this
I really can't believe anything never
mind New York City this was in the mayor
yeah Mayor de Blasio this is de Blasio
absolutely in the day this could be
breakfast okay
I want you to look at this and think
about
again
some people love hamburger some don't I
hope he chokes at the end of this video
if this is appealing to you just think
of this when you think of vaccination
um
I'm getting a very good feeling you're
so funny
about vaccination right this moment when
they started like paying people like
literally giving people money and free
stuff to get vaccinated that's when I
was like all right well I'm definitely
not getting it now yeah that's insane I
remember when I first got to college
that you would get like a hundred dollar
gift card to the bookstore people like
oh I can buy my combine my books if I
get vaccinated dude you really that's
that's why you're getting vaccinated
that's [ __ ] crazy
oh my God look at this
oh my God
oh Lord
[Laughter]
oh good job kitty cat wait what
oh holy [ __ ]
oh Lord Oh Lord Oh Lord look at this
this lady is crazy
oh Lord go back out to Russell Brand see
what he's doing they took down a rumble
for misinformation but why are beer that
is so funny we need more crazy [ __ ]
remember the lady the fire the lady who
who escaped from the fire and she became
a viral sensation with her news
interview she was absolutely the best
thing if you can find her and we can end
on that note because it's the funniest
wait what is it it was that lady who
escaped from the fire and oh my God she
was it was Joy just sheer Joy watching
her interview
oh that's bugs
[Music]
that's why I stay inside oh that's so
good
oh my God
[Music]
I thought that was snow
holy [ __ ] are you even looking this lady
I am the daily spectator woman gives
funny interview after a fire okay if you
haven't seen this lady this was this is
from six years ago and it was Mom moment
no it's not everybody loved this lady I
know I know it's so old I don't care
it'll make me happy and then we're going
to dinner we'll come back later though
my friend came to the girl she said well
I was on the phone cooking me and my
babies for the breakfast and she said
hey something wrong is popping I said
why she said yeah I said no so the girl
come downstairs she come out her
apartment with her baby with no shoes on
I said oh girl it's cold outside she
said something ain't right I said oh man
she said oh man the building is on fire
I said no what I got my three kids and
we bounced out we ain't gonna be in no
fire not the dude
come on if that doesn't just make your
day every day that's funny she's as good
as the eight nobody got time for that
lady ain't nobody got time for that
oh
I guess we're not
oh come on this is the [ __ ] that's on
Twitter
oh
oh I hate people people are so cringy
yeah I want to leave this planet I don't
know what we're going elon's next ship
what are you laughing about
Twitter Twitter
oh my God they're so addicted we're so
addicted I can't believe anybody's gonna
watch this nonsense with us watching
this nonsense we can make a whole
YouTube video out of just watching
stupid Twitter videos watch out oh
you know what they they're not nice to
those animals every now and then when
when somebody gets gored I kind of root
for the bowl
oh
let's go back look that was a mouse oh
in the fryer later
look at this look at this
oh wait let's stop here and I'm gonna
just tell the story you were about five
and we were we were out with cousin Rob
for the day and we were just walking
down Newbury Street in Boston and sunny
was so happy he was a happy little kid
but you know this tall and he's walking
along and he's talking to us and we're
talking and he just walks and he's full
speed slams his head right into a
parking meter and big you know those
hard steel parking meters the old school
ones that you put the coins in and you
just you just stepped back and you were
in shock for a second and then you
started hysterical crying and me and
cousin Rob just started hysterical
laughing we could not stop laughing we
laughed so hard we were crying we were
the worst adults in the world that was
right outside I picked you up and I was
hugging you and rubbing you back but I
was a hysterical laughing and I tried
not to not show you oh I love when kids
do that [ __ ] that was on Salem Street
right that was on Newberry Street oh
that was on Newberry Street yeah are you
sure yes I'm sure it's so weird how I
can remember being somewhere totally
different yeah there weren't meters on
Salem Street anyway all right guys all
right I'm going out to to eat we're
gonna go eat something and we'll be back
I feel like that's all we ever goes
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]